[Music]
the year is 2020 it's september
i just want to be the one to point out
this is the third folding phone in a row
getting a video what a time to be alive
what's up mkbhd here and this is a
samsung galaxy z fold 2
5g
the fold 2 brought to you by optical
flow of course
and this is the only phone that folds
that i can actually recommend any group
of people actually buy
in 2020 it's still expensive it's 2 000
bucks and it's still got its compromises
the tech inside is still very young
but this is the best one this is the
king but for every reason out there that
this is the king of folding phones
there's another reason why you probably
still shouldn't buy one yet
a big part of why the fold 2 is so good
is the hardware this generation 2.5
hardware here is the most evolved so
this build even makes the previous
galaxy folds look a little sloppy like
it's boxier it's more squared off it's
tighter the hinge is firmer and i still
i love this satin finish and the brushed
metal look of course it is truly samsung
improving in a ton of places at once but
also fundamentally
it's still a kind of awkward galaxy fold
form factor that we're used to there's
still a gap between the screens when
it's closed and it is still pretty thick
it's still a chunky candy bar phone when
it's closed which is a little awkward to
hold and definitely a solid chunk in
your pocket so it's a little give a
little take but i think obviously the
biggest change you'll notice the most
impressive thing you will instantly
recognize
is the new screens both on the inside
and outside they are technically
speaking a massive improvement they are
spec for spec everything you would have
wanted them to improve
but in use
these actually also turn out to be kind
of a win-lose so on the outside of
course way bigger full screen corner to
corner 6.2 inch cover display way better
looking way more modern just a hole
punch selfie camera up top clearly this
is an improvement it's what we were all
thinking when we saw the first fold when
are they gonna fill up that screen and
now they did but the funny thing is
okay part of the dynamic of having that
tiny cover screen on the old fold i've
talked about this in the review is it's
actually a barrier to entry to getting
lost in your phone so if you just need
to do something real quick like you get
a text you want to reply or just change
the song in spotify or just something
real quick in the notifications you do
that on the tiny cover screen and then
you turn it off and you're done because
you don't want to use the tiny screen
very much but if you really do need to
get something done then okay you got a
galaxy fold you open it up and you use
the main screen but now that outside
screen is so big you can actually use it
more often and it's not so bad you can
kind of just use that outside like a
normal smartphone it is a little narrow
so typing is still kind of compressed
and the aspect ratio is a bit odd
sometimes with some apps but actually
found myself one-handed scrolling
through twitter or instagram or relay
for reddit or just kind of burning time
on the outside screen in a way i never
would have on the tiny front screen
before
and now reachability is actually more of
a problem because the screen is so tall
now that it can be kind of hard to reach
the top one-handed so weirdly what's
happening is getting this way bigger
better outside screen
made me more comfortable just staying on
the outside screen just hanging out on
the outside like a normal phone
which is a terrible habit to get into
because clearly the inside screen
is amazing this is where all the magic
happens the main display here on the
fold 2 is pretty much all win and this
is what makes the galaxy fold so fun to
use and such a king really it's bigger
it's brighter bezels are smaller notches
have disappeared and it's now bumped up
to 120 hertz it's such a win that you
know that you can carry around a screen
like this in your pocket at all
is awesome every time i unfold it i just
kind of want to find something to do so
i can keep using it it's so great the
sad thing is the software experience
mostly the app optimization is still
catching up to this odd aspect ratio
since it basically is a mini tablet and
there is also now a setting in the fold
too that lets you use tablet mode with
some apps that support it instead of
just big blown up phone mode so there's
columns and everything now but a lot of
apps still have trouble looking good on
this squarish aspect ratio videos hardly
ever fill it up unless you're watching a
brandon havard video maybe there's also
always huge black bars instagram and a
lot of other apps are just kind of weird
blown up phone versions even the camera
viewfinder isn't quite filling up the
whole display and that can kinda cheapen
the experience but every once in a while
there are some good apps where you turn
it 90 degrees and you're in that columns
mode and tablet mode like spotify or
gmail and this thing becomes
so great it's a productivity machine
i was loving that i think a world where
all my favorite apps have a version like
that to take advantage of this display
is going to be awesome
it's just that's not quite the world the
galaxy fold lives in yet and i also
found something quite interesting with
the battery so in making the fold my
daily driver i was a little bit
concerned i was going to pay attention
to the battery right it's a bigger
outside screen a bigger and 120 hertz
inside screen
and the battery's not seeing a huge bump
up so i'm going to pay attention to
battery right so i'm testing the phone
i'm using it like every day and i'm
starting to notice i'm getting to the
end of days with
more battery than i did on the old fold
like i'm ending days with like 35 45
left
and i was thinking about it and it turns
out it's not because of some crazy
optimization it's not the new specs it's
not some bigger internal battery or some
hack
it was because i'm i'm using this
smaller 60 hertz display so much more
than i was on the old fold that i was
actually saving battery that way so this
is just a weird usage habit that i
picked up of course your mileage may
vary i think there's going to be people
that get this phone and like never ever
want to use the outside candy bar
display and i totally get it it's it's
kind of jarring actually going back and
forth between 60 hertz and 120 hertz and
such a weird aspect ratio
but i'm just telling you how it ended up
for me battery was improved because i
was using the outside display more than
i expected to so when you put it all
together
galaxy z fold 2 right now
is the folding phone king it's the best
folding phone in a lot of ways like it's
got the best specs of any foldable
that's for sure snapdragon 865 plus
12 gigs of ram it's the only one i think
with wireless charging other than the
z-flip it's got the best set of cameras
in any foldable coming in pretty much
around the same tier as galaxy s20 it
doesn't have all the the super highest
end features like space zoom or 8k video
but it'll still do 10x zoom and it is
still a triple camera with a main a
telephoto and an ultra wide that you can
also use as your selfie camera thanks to
a software feature so you're going to
deliver photos that are still very
clearly very easily samsung flagship
photos with all their hdr and bright and
vibrant look which is great
it's got some of the best battery of any
foldable even minus my anecdote of using
the outside screen more it's still
packing a 4 500 milliamp hour dual
battery and that's been more than enough
for regular use and it's got the best
screens of any foldable and maybe this
is debatable but it's easily the best
brightness colors and resolution an
amazing thin bezel 2k 120 hertz amoled
inside it's just so sick that you can
get this in your pocket it even has the
best fingerprint reader from my
experience right on the power button
it's got the best speakers i've heard in
a foldable for sure
and one of the best hinges now that
they've tightened it up and given it a
more confident feeling firmer hinge that
can stay in place at multiple angles
plus a couple software tricks to take
advantage of it like special modes with
youtube and the camera app if you can
remember to use them they're kind of
cool so thanks to samsung having the
most iterations to work on this i'd say
this is like 2.5
this is the king
right now
in 2020
but for what though
like what does it mean to be
the best
thing in a category that most people
should still avoid in 2020 right now
like if this is the best we can do and
this is the best screen in a foldable
but you still have a pretty pronounced
crease that the eye can still catch from
various angles it's the king
but
for what if this is the best we can do
with ultra thin glass but there's still
a factory installed screen protector
with the edges all the way around it
that samsung tells people not to remove
themselves but it's always going to
collect dust around the camera cut out
where you can clearly see they took a
shortcut
it's it's the king
but for what if this is the best we can
do with a confident well-engineered
hinge that hopefully doesn't have any
durability issues in the future and lets
you feel like you have the most control
over the phone and the software layer on
top of android does as much as it can to
help continuity between the outside
screen
and the inside screen
but still 75 percent of apps look like a
stretched awkward version of themselves
every time you open them up
it's the king
but for what so even though this is the
best folding phone
it's also still super obvious that this
is nowhere near the end of the line it's
nowhere near mature yet first of all
there's still compromises like the
outside screen
is still slightly worse than a normal
smartphone because it's it's suit tall
and narrow and chunky to hold
and then the inside screen is also still
slightly worse than a normal tablet
because it's a little smaller and it's a
little squarer and it has a crease and
number two it's still expensive it's 2
000 bucks
for that price
it's always crazy to make comparisons
but you could get
an ipad pro
and a pixel 4a
and some sony noise canceling headphones
and probably have money left over but
there's something you get with the
galaxy fold too that you don't really
get anywhere else which is the most
complete most evolved
foldable phone so far
that you can actually get and having all
that stuff in one device that you can
fit in your pocket
that's a pretty sweet start
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace